allez bien là des choses à faire d'abord
il faut que je m'habille et que je me
coiffe les témoins comme toute allure
mais non vous rejetez pas coiffée non je
suis quoi faire avec effet pas coiffer
la violence a vraiment l'expression des
faits quoi c'est à dire
désolé rixe un moment très blessée très
humain le point positif c'est que tu
n'es pas décoiffée
et pas la projo jolicoeur mais pour
qu'on parle de toi un homme ça veut dire
quoi devenir un autre savoir devenir
comme vous le type qui vivent ensemble
avec un petit chien
jolis cheveux
chez nous en bretagne c'est assez
fréquent deux hommes qui vivent ensemble
ah mais ça n'a rien à voir là on habite
ensemble c'est plus d'esprit ne suis
comme une colocation